foreign
[Music]
amazing weekend and I want to tell you
about it go for it I want to hear about
it all right so
uh we've done these before but I'll
explain kind of how they work for for
people who are listening so about once a
year maybe twice a year we do these kind
of like friends slash founder weekend
hangout type thing so by the way sorry
you should have been there I don't know
why the invite got lost in the mail
don't worry about that oh I'm worried
about it you're lucky I could you're
lucky I couldn't have made it but I'm
worried about it I was gonna text you
um while we were doing it and I was like
wait why isn't Sam here and I was like
Ben do we did Sam say no or did we not
tell Sam and then he was like I don't
know this whole thing got screwed up uh
because we whatever we bumped it back
twice and then this happened anyway so
um once twice a year go somewhere rent
an Airbnb
uh four to five kind of founder friends
and hang out and the but this one was
different this this one was a intimate
birthday thing as opposed to last time
we did it it was like a 20 person one
um maybe yeah I don't even remember it
got bumped back twice so at this point
who knows um but basically it was like
all right start the new year let's all
get together hang out and do whatever
and so we um we go to San Diego we rent
um an Airbnb from Mark Jenny who you've
talked about on the Pod before just to
explain what he's doing he founded a
company called RV share which was like
Airbnb for renting RVs and grew that
sold that for I think a hundred million
dollars and part of it yeah I think he's
part of it yeah private Equity to KKR I
believe I think he's actually sold twice
so he sold one chunk the first time
second chunk recently and um and I think
he still owns a piece of it but anyways
RV share a really successful business
he's got a crazy story where I think he
was like homeless at one point in time
and and made the whole thing happen
we'll have him on shortly but very
inspirational person he now has an airbn
a luxury Airbnb portfolio worth about 50
million dollars and so he's got I don't
know 20-something properties and he goes
for the over-the-top kind of like
destination experience uh
you know maybe like party type of
um houses so this house like like family
parties
family or like uh buddies going for a
golf trip
um you know type of thing where it's
like like his one of his most successful
properties that is in Scottsdale Arizona
and we're like Scottsdale why he's like
oh people guys go there for golf trips
and so you know eight buddies get
together and they rent my place and it's
great and they all have money and so the
price isn't as big of an issue or
whatever so this one is in San Diego and
um the backyard I think this guy must
have put
somewhere between one and two million
dollars into the backyard so he um we
get you go outside there's a basketball
court there's a pickleball court there's
a wiffle ball field with a fence like a
full baseball diamond basically there is
golf course there is like pool sauna
everything you could think of it is like
a boy uh you know boy Paradise basically
little boy Paradise it's perfect for us
right but that's all we were doing you
go inside the house you know there's
like a full poker table with the poker
set with the perfect chairs there's pool
table there's all kinds of good stuff
anyways so we get there
and um
a couple of really cool things happen uh
one Mark came over for dinner uh he's
like uh you know hosted dinner for us
there and he was telling us his story
which is kind of crazy but I kind of
want to save that bit for the podcast
um I've asked him to come on tons of
times by the way he turns me down and
I'm good friends at Mark and he turns me
down he's like oh no I'm with my family
all summer and yeah he just had a baby
so I think I'm like I appreciate that I
appreciate it I think he'll do it um
he's definitely he listens to the Pod so
you know instead of listening one day
for that hour just come on and talk like
it's no extra time for you Mark and so
then the next uh so we we kind of hang
out first day is just straight Sports
mail bonding sweaty male bonding let's
call it and uh we're just playing every
sport that's there uh and in between we
sort of talk business or whatever second
day we I tweeted out I go who's in San
Diego
and a bunch of people replied Ben goes
through curates and is just like all
right these 15 people seem cool I'm
gonna invite them over to the house so
they come over the house and I just want
to set the scene of this kind of like
party uh first of all
first of all this whole segment should
be called Sean leaves the house because
I'm explaining how cool this was this is
probably a monthly occurrence for you uh
to me I was like dude I left the house I
met all these cool people it was amazing
because I never leave my house and so
this time I was out of my house I met a
bunch of cool people but you still
didn't leave the state
I didn't leave the state no I I barely
got on a flight so so so here's the
scene in the room uh there is two guys
who own nft projects that have probably
done 200 plus million in sales wow um
they're both under the age of 23 mid 24
maybe
um so that's kind of crazy
one of them one of them didn't even have
a public identity until like you know a
month ago so that was uh people know
Frank from from D Gods so D Gods was the
number one project on Solana uh it's
like the board Apes of Solana and um
and yeah he basically uh he just kind of
said hey hey here's my real identity
whatever so he can now show up to
parties and say what he does whereas
before he couldn't do that
um okay second thing uh so that's one
group then there was the d2c crew these
are people who have built products that
like created a product uh one guy
um created this thing called gel
blasters think like a Nerf gun or a BB
gun but just with like gel pellets I
love that um it went from like zero to I
don't know if I'm allowed to say the
number but tens of millions in Revenue
in a year and then like has a crazy
story uh I'm gonna get him on the Pod
too to come tell this story but has a
crazy story of sort of getting screwed
over by one of the big toy companies
they pretended to buy his company for
like 100 million bucks and then he like
does the diligence with them shows them
all the design files the cad files the
everything the specs of the product they
fall out and then three months later
launched like an identical product to to
compete with them and like Steel his
influencer marketing plan everything is
a kind of crazy story there
um other people in the room
remember the mini Katana guy we talked
about Isaac he came so he's there and
he's showing me like how they basically
do eight figures in Revenue without a
single Dollar on ads and it's not out of
Pride like he just can't advertise
because it's like Facebook's like yo
this is a weapon you can't advertise
swords on Facebook so he had to get
creative and was just like okay how do I
make organic content that's so good you
want to buy a sword tens of millions of
dollars worth of this sword and um I
thought that was pretty remarkable
really super nice guy that came over
um
and he's like dude I was listening to
the podcast while driving and I heard
you guys talking about a katana store
and I was like he's like I almost drove
off the road I was like no are they
talking about me who are they talking
about and he's like that was a surreal
moment
um
all right so he's there uh a guy you
know a former CIA operative came who I
think you interviewed for the Pod you
did a pod with him and then we couldn't
release it
yeah we don't even need to say more
because that already sounds juicy as a
mother effort right we couldn't release
it because uh he said a bunch of
classified stuff and so this person I
don't even know what I can say now but
basically
this is me speaking not him
um but it's almost as if they convince
people in other countries to become
treasonous spies yeah spies is part of
the trees if you've watched Jack Ryan
this was like the real life Jack Ryan
and we asked him all about that and then
he left the government and he created a
business and so there was a good overlap
so I'm gonna tell you one so I'm don't
say his name though by the way yeah yeah
I'm not gonna do it so I was like uh I
was like so how do you do it how do you
convince somebody
you're just this like you know American
person coming into their country you
know you go into Afghanistan or wherever
you know Yemen or someplace
um how do you convince them to like you
know work for the US government to help
us
and he's like well
um
like two years of Rapport building and
then it's you know it's manipulation
right like you were trying to and I was
like so how would you do that like I
feel like you couldn't do that and he's
like remember earlier uh when we were
grabbing a drink you said you really
want X and I was like no it's like in
passing I must have said something he's
like
for about a year I will basically talk
to this person and I'll find out they're
every want their every need their every
problem and I'm keeping a file and I'm
keeping this file for years before I
flip them and I was like Wow uh and this
person's really I don't want to talk
anymore he's very charming and he's very
likable and when he tells great stories
when he tells a story you're captivated
he's gotten it factor and so when I was
with them I was like oh yeah I
understand why uh I would I would Commit
This thing in order to like uh you know
please you right so he told one story
amazing I called four people over you
got to hear this you got to hear this
come here
tell another one
he's like um
and I'm like [__] I just yeah you're
like hey you're funny tell a joke then
he tells another Banger and I'm like and
everybody's like oh wow to the last
three people who didn't hear the first
one get over here get over here get over
here
hey you got another one
and he's like oh you know you know the
thing is uh you know blah blah he's kind
of having it hung and I was like look
if the story [__] no problem you're
already you already won this is just a
bonus lap if it's terrible I have no
problem with you I already think you're
amazing I just depressurized the moment
for a second and I was like you know
just try to give us one more he gives us
one more and I was like wow this is a
you know my friend Jason Hitchcock has
this thing he says he goes uh you say
one interesting thing I say huh
interesting two interesting things I
said those are interesting three
interesting things I say you are
interesting and that's what happened by
the third one I was like you are
interesting uh that's how I felt so that
guy was kind of amazing and by the way
I'll say um this kind of sucks to talk
about because I can't reveal a lot but
you and I have a friend and this person
um is related to a bunch of like seals
and CIA people and it just so happens
that there's this weird community of
like these xcia NSA seals all these like
you know abbreviators yeah and well they
they get out and they go and they start
businesses because like I think I say
have a pension so they have a little bit
of money
um like they have some of their basic
needs covered and then they go and start
businesses and we're they're in our
world successful and they're very
successful and it's I love hanging out
with these guys you know and and they're
like proper Heroes and then they're like
talking to me about like internet and
CAC and I'm like yeah but what about
Isis like tell me tell me sorry about
that like tell me that time you
eliminated 18 Isis people you know what
I mean it's like they're Heroes it's fun
talking to these guys yeah and then um
let's see who else so then uh our buddy
Ramon is there Ramones there with his
son and and uh Ramon's telling us
Amazing Stories has he ever told you the
uh contractor Story the best thing I've
ever heard yeah you want to retell it
yeah can I retell it here yeah I don't
know when the next time he's gonna be on
but he's like um and he's officially
he's an American now Ramon's an American
so that was the big thing he's
officially an American we go out to
before he arrives we go out we get him a
cake from like the Safeway there or
whatever and we're like um hey
can you write a message on here like now
it's closed for the day I was like bro
you gotta write a message and you know
convince the guy he writes a message uh
welcome to America uh misspell's welcome
so it just says welcome to America like
sounds like the most non-american thing
ever and that's right um he and I was
like you know so you got your
citizenship that's amazing what happened
afterwards and his son Victor was like
oh man in the car afterwards everybody
who was calling he would just answer
hello fellow Americans
so that was amazing so he's uh at the
dinner party we're like you know
tell us a story uh no we were like um
what's an icebreaker for a group like
this it's like what's the what's the
um weirdest way you tried to make a buck
like what's the weirdest way you try to
make money because otherwise in this
type of scenario if you kind of say oh
so what do you do people just go into
their script yeah yeah and it's kind of
the whole thing's just kind of
pretentious because it's a room full of
successful people and everybody starts
kind of one-upping each other in this
weird way so instead you want to like
nag the whole group so this is the neg
the whole group question what's the
weirdest way you tried to make a buck
um and Ramon's like uh you know he's got
like 10 of these and we're like dude
this is the thing about Ramon he's very
quiet but when you start getting himself
story it's like a vending machine like a
endless vending machine of stories
you've never heard of even though you
know the guy for 10 years so he's like
yeah uh back in the day I was like okay
I want to start a construction uh what
is it I'm gonna start a painting
business he's like oh I need money I'm
18 years old I'll uh paint walls so he
puts up a thing that's like I'll paint
walls
but you know being the Hustler that he
is he's like
I'll you know what how can I widen the
top of this funnel let me just say
painting handy van I'll fix anything
whatever you got I'm in general I'm a
general contractor I'll do generally
anything and uh so he's 18 years only
puts up his listing on the like the
Dutch Craigslist like that and um he
gets an increase next days it says hey
um I need an electrician for some
electrical work and he's like great be
there tomorrow morning he's like
um he's like I go to the store at Like
Home Depot type store and I'm looking at
like these vests I'm like which one
looks more like an electrician like
basically it's like Halloween he's like
trying to find a costume and he's like I
go there the next day and the guy's like
um cool yeah so we need like you know uh
40 amps here and we're gonna do we're
gonna run a line under the circuit over
here he's like dude he's saying words
like forget about knowing how to do it I
don't even understand the words he's
saying and he has a clipboard though but
he's like reading his writing notes he's
wearing the vest
yeah yeah okay tell me more and he's
like just because I just keep scrolling
it's like a very complicated job he's
like I hoped it was I was like dude
what'd you think was gonna happen he's
like I hoped it was like light bulbs
like he's like electrical electricity
yeah I don't know light bulbs and he's
like once I got there I was like oh [__]
um but I'm writing I don't know what to
say I don't know what to do so I'm like
okay maybe I can figure it out you know
open up the cert the open up the the
thing there's just a thousand wires I'm
like okay there's no way I know what to
do here and so he's like um yeah listen
man uh I think he tells him this the
next day or something yeah he goes home
yeah he goes home but he thinks about it
and he reflects and he's like I gotta
come clean to this guy like I don't know
how to do I don't know anything I don't
know what to do and he's like reviewing
his notes he's like I don't know what
any of this means yes he goes back he's
like I gotta tell you man um I've never
done electrical
he's like I just needed money I thought
I could figure it out and um slept on it
turns out I can't I have no idea how to
do this and the guy was like what the
[__] everything's also like you know
what kid like he's like I'm an
entrepreneur he's like um I respect the
hustle I expect that you were honest and
he's like everyone's like you know when
you're honest and you're young
um like good things happen and the guy
he's like gave me a great lesson he's
like you know what like instead of
telling me like don't ever do this again
he was like actually uh you know what
you should do is you don't need to know
how to do electrical work you got the
job now you need to find somebody who
does know electric work and subcontract
it out and keep a margin and so you
shouldn't be here anyways he should be
doing that and he's like oh and he
started an actual like general
contracting business doing that from
there and the guy like helped him out um
basically gave him a job and helped him
out and that eventually he did that for
a couple years and he actually made
maybe uh for sure hundreds of thousands
I think he made close to a million
dollars I think his first million was
running that business and then he
immigrated to America and he created a
uh Brazilian
Music Festival I have no idea why and he
lost all of it and then he created more
internet business and made it all again
and then lost it all again and then made
it all again and so he's done that a
bunch of times very fascinating guy
yeah even his current business so he has
his business called Alpha paw
and he sells like great dog products or
dog ramps things like that and uh even
that like whip up up up and then hits a
then like you know when covet happen
shipping costs went through the roof so
like a container for shipping used to
cost three thousand dollars then it
started costing twenty thousand dollars
so like a six hour increase and when you
have a huge product you need a lot it
takes up a lot of space so you need a
lot of containers so his his unit cost
blew up that was really tough and but
he's so resilient so like he he's like
all right what's the pivot and he
pivoted to he's like dogs having trouble
cats and so he's like all right and he
made this kitty litter product called
genius litter and now he just got a deal
where he's now in PetSmart Nationwide
which is amazing and now he's like back
back you know in the now it's like dude
I need so if you're listening to this
you know the gentleman's agreement to go
smash subscribe but also if you have a
cat or you don't have a cat you got a
dog it doesn't matter what you got go to
PetSmart buy this guy's genius litter so
his business uh you know thrives because
this guy deserves the best guy I know so
um you know so just amazing Stories one
after another of each person about like
bouncing back so there was a bunch of
like I don't know takeaways I had from
this number one
storytelling wins there was a bunch of
people at this event that were all
equally impressive but it was the ones
who understood how to tell a story that
stood out and that everybody loved made
a bunch of connections people started
helping them out they're like oh you
should try XYZ oh you got to meet blah
blah blah and it was the people that
didn't understand how to tell their
story they only told facts
and it was just sort of like I I'm you
know whatever I'm Steve that's what I do
blah blah everything's been great
all right thanks Steve see ya you know
like you know yeah you need some of that
Sizzle yeah you they didn't have that
Sizzle and so the sizzle the story
telling Sizzle was so important and so
obvious and then there's nuances like
there were some people that were
storytellers that every story was how
awesome they were and you could just see
it was like just repelling people like
here's how awesome I am and then slowly
but surely okay great got one of those
stories I'm gonna go get a drink now see
ya and it was the person who could tell
a story that was like slightly making
fun of themselves even the CIA guy he
goes oh I have a rule I only tell CIA
stories where I look like an idiot
um I never tell CIA stories where I you
know I beat the bad guys I fought five
guys and then everybody clapped he's
like I'll never tell a story like that
and so I was like that's a great rule in
general for people so that I think that
was like one big takeaway second
takeaway is
I should probably leave the house a
little more often this was dope and um I
used to do this all the time and I kind
of got a little cocky and was just sort
of like yeah I got a great Network you
know I don't really need to like put in
like this but when I was in my 20s I
used to do this all the time and this
was just a reminder of how much value
you can get by talking to other people
in the game or like you know I think
this podcast serves as that for people
too where you hear these stories you get
inspired you get ideas growth hacks and
um and it's surprising how helpful
people are so you know what I describe
that as you when you're around certain
people you realize that the world is
malleable and you see all types of
people who are bending the world to the
reality that they want and then you feel
like oh yeah that's cool I can do that
too so it doesn't matter you're like I
don't care for selling if you're if
you're in the CIA if you're selling
genius litter it doesn't matter it's
just cool to see people who are kicking
their Dent into the universe right yeah
exactly exactly and um
second thing I would say is there was a
huge difference in life phase attitude
all right what does that mean
so we at this event so we had Ramon's
son and his friend uh shout out to Jude
he came so he's a fun kid too he's super
fun kid super chatty chatty Kathy and uh
but by the way the next day he was like
he was holding up the gel Blaster gun
thing he's like so they said they make
this for whatever makeup numbers they
make this for three dollars and they
sell it for nine I was like dude he's
already picking it up this guy's like 10
or 11. he's like that's a really big
like you know margin and I was like wow
you know margin that's that's really
impressive
um
so so anyways we had people that were 10
or 11 we had the guys who were kind of
like 20 to 25 the nft boys and then and
D to see some of the DDC guys we had
guys like us who were in our 30s and we
were like all right yeah and I'll tell
you the differences and and how each one
was approaching it in a second we had
guys in their 40s so that's like you
know you know that sort of thing
um and then we had then I went and met
up with a guy in his 70s and like a
husband and wife in their 70s so
I saw all those life phases I want you
to guess what do you think was the like
notable like differences in those ages
in terms of like what they cared about
what they thought about what were the
differences have you ever heard the
story of like there's like an old bowl
and a young bowl and they see a bunch of
cows and the young bull goes let's hurry
up and get down there and have sex with
all them cows in the old Bowl is like
whoa whoa whoa we can walk we could we
could walk down there we could take our
time and that's kind of the difference I
imagine the 22 year olds are like let's
do everything the 30 year olds were a
little bit wiser the 40 year olds were
like hey let's just pick and choose our
battles a little bit more wisely like
let's enjoy the process of the
seven-year-olds were more so like uh
none of it matters yeah exactly that's
exactly right so the the T the teens or
pre-teens they were basically just like
you want to play what's what are we
gonna play hey you guys want to play
this while we play this it's like we
were on the pickleball court and then in
between points they're running and
kicking the soccer ball and then right
afterwards like you want to play
Monopoly you want to do this and like
till the last minute of the last second
of the day it was like you want to play
yeah and I thought that was like you
know just an awesome energy to be around
the other part of it was like um
they
also were doing Khan Academy a bunch and
I was like wow they really like want to
learn this stuff like that's kind of
cool
um you know that's that's kind of
amazing that just kind of blew me away
so they were all about play Then you had
your guys in your 20s that were the I
got it all figured out guys and I
remember being that guy and it's like
they actually do have a lot of Life
figured out their way ahead of the curve
but the problem is they think they're at
the end of the curve they think they got
it all figured out and so you listen to
stories and they're saying things and
you're like you know what four out of
the ten things you just said were
totally wrong
but you know what it doesn't matter it
the fact that you believe all 10 is
gonna work and um and I just love that
you think all ten are right I love like
what are the odds that's a good way to
summarize it yeah
um but they were they were a lot of fun
and their thing was just sort of like
we're going huge like of course this is
gonna work uh this is gonna be massive
we got it figured out and um not in a
cocky way just like
they had only known winning and uh and I
thought that was awesome because as you
get older you start to take L's you take
Health L's you take you see friends take
L's you make big expensive mistakes you
take those L's and that sort of humbles
you a little bit and so this was pretty
humbling and I loved it I loved that
energy uh because you know even at first
I was like
man these guys are delusional and then I
was like how do I hey pass the delusion
please I'd like to sip on some of that
uh that's a lot of fun actually I forgot
how useful that can be
um all right guys in their 30s like us
weird middle State it's like I have a
lot of self-belief but I now know how
expensive it is to go down the wrong
path whereas the guys in their 20s don't
know how expensive it is to go down the
wrong path wait they don't even know
anything about the path though I'm just
pathing I'm just passing bro I'm just on
the path I don't even think about the
fact that I could be doing five other
things I'm doing this and this makes
completely complete sense to me whereas
the 30s were like you could do this I
could do that and they're almost
paralysis by analysis yeah um they've
accomplished too much too much to just
do something stupid like the guys in
their 20s who created this nft project
they were able to just do something
stupid and it paid off they created this
uh this you know gel Blaster Nerf gun
because it just was stupid and they
thought it was cool and like that was
enough justification to do it oh that
looks fun do it where's the guys
interviews like that looks fun but uh
let's let's spreadsheet this out real
quick and just see well you know let's
back at the envelope yeah like um when
you have something to lose it changes a
little bit right and so they back at the
envelope themselves to death but you
know they're still at least they're
still thinking of the the difference was
when you compare to the 40s the 40s were
like we know what we're doing
um when I hear about what all these
other guys are doing I'm half amused and
half of it exhausts me and I want to go
take a nap like you're just confusing me
with all these things that honestly like
I don't feel like I need to know any of
this stuff I I I'm perfectly happy not
being in nfts and not knowing how to do
Tick Tock videos to sell mini swords
like that's cool
but man I just want to go relax right
now and the second thing was they were
like one of them just like found out he
was high blood pressure so he had a
blood pressure monitor with him and he
was like um just took his blood pressure
and we were like I was like dude I never
take my blood pressure put me in and so
we took our blood pressure like four
times a day just for fun but I was like
you know they were like like you said
they wanted to enjoy the journey so they
were like yeah yeah we could talk
business but like let's go play some
pickleball that'd be fine yeah and I
think um as you get older you you you
respect all the different ways that you
can get there but you know you're lame
I know my lane and I know if I just do
this all the time for I know what
compounding looks like and everybody
else looks very scatterbrained in
comparison uh but the no other laners
and I don't mean that in a discouraging
way like they were they were definitely
learning and and they've they've made
adjustments but they weren't seeking the
next hit they were just like I found a
hit and I enjoy this hit and I want to
also think about life and marriage and
kids and health and that was a way
bigger part of their their life like
their their own mortality was more on
their mind than proving themselves like
the 20s and 30s and the older I get and
the more experienced I get I understand
compounding better I that was that that
was a really hard thing for me to
understand in my early 20s and late 20s
and then once I like start seeing it
work a little bit you start
understanding it and you go oh wow so if
I just do this all the time for 10 years
like look at the uh I'll be in a better
place than I will be if I start a bunch
of different things and yes uh so you
understand compounding a little bit
better so you know well if I just stay
in my Lane I can respect everyone else's
what they're doing that's neat and I
think that's cool and I can learn but if
I just do this mostly the same I'm gonna
I'm gonna get to where I wanna go
yeah so that was the 40s and then the
70s were basically like
some Contra come with some combination
of I want to contribute so they were
like pitching me a project that was like
a philanthropic thing and I was like
philanthropy oh okay that's what this is
a different conversation that everybody
else says all the other conversations
I've been having all weekend and the
second thing was
they were just happy we came over to
their house it's like when we were
leaving I was like man it's gonna be
really quiet once we leave here like is
this uh
oh man that's kind of huh who was the
person can you say um I don't say their
name just because I'm gonna like you
know tell maybe I don't know what I'm
gonna say about them so I don't want to
say their name but like kind of like a
successful entrepreneurial couple in San
Diego
um and so I was like you know I went to
their house and I was like they were
really nice really cool hosted us but
also what's that fat house
uh semi-fat house yeah like nice
um
yeah nice house but also when you see a
house at night by the way it's like uh
you don't actually see the house because
you can't see anything around it and you
can't see like you know you only see
like a part of it it's just very
different when you see house at night
first during the day
um
but I just felt like the things that
matter to them were their grandkids
their kids marrying the right person
figuring out how to like contribute and
also just like
their house not being so quiet there's
like any liveliness in the house uh it
was like a win it didn't even really
matter what we talked about or what came
out of it like I feel like us being
there was a cool
fun change of pace and I was like yeah I
guess when I'm in my 70s I'm also going
to want that a lot because I'll probably
be kind of like
at home kind of bored a bunch you know
and so that was like also kind of a
wake-up call for me it was like oh wow
yeah yeah this life thing does go pretty
fast here
dude so it sounds like a sick weekend
yeah it was a lot of fun that's badass
yeah I have to talk to Ramona I gotta I
want to learn all about it
um or from his perspective but it sounds
like a sick weekend yeah that should
happen every six months
yeah I think yeah I think we should do
that uh again and also the um it was
cool that um like even the house we were
in was kind of like a business it was
like this every this luxury Airbnb
itself is a business and uh and it just
kind of breaks your frame a little bit
like I think that's a pretty important
thing like how how often can you break
your frame
um and an experience like this twice a
year I think twice a year you'll end up
breaking your frame because you'll just
meet a bunch of other people to do life
and think about life in a different way
than you I actually want to ask you
about like a frame breaking experience
um before I get into that I have to
remind people that they owe us
they're in debt to us if you just heard
Sean's story he just went and spent the
weekend creating these things to tell
you about and then he like did all this
work to do it and we do that every week
three two times a week two to three
times a week you're in debt to us so you
owe us this is the gentleman's agreement
part where you have to go to YouTube
even if you're on iTunes or you're on
podcasts or you're on Spotify go to
iTunes right now my first million click
subscribe and that's our gentleman's
agreement and we'll be even and we'll be
actually more than even because we're
going to keep doing this and we're
working for you once you subscribe
that's all it's like a it's the most
fair trade because once you subscribe we
get in the algorithm yada yada but this
is the gentleman's agreement part we
can't check that you're doing this
that's why it's called the gentleman's
agreement is we just hope that you are
so please do that
um and argue with that you can't argue
with that that's the they spent
literally one second to click subscribe
and we spend 30 hours a week coming up
this content it's a very fair trade
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
I want to ask you about a frame breaking
thing now that your how long has it been
since the milk Road acquisition
um two months maybe a month and a half
something like that so you're still
early into it um this February 1st is
technically my last day at HubSpot
that's two years so
um and so now I'm two years into it and
I've wanted to ask you and I have a list
here but I wanted to ask you uh because
uh I know that the guys running the milk
road now or the owners are like
recruiting interesting people because I
like people like message me they go hey
this person's recruiting me should I
join milk road so like I'm getting all
these like ass uh like to as your
reference check
um what have you learned so far about
what it's like to be the founder of a
company that's now owned by someone else
is there anything interesting that
you've learned I have a a list of a few
things that are interesting to me but is
there anything you've learned uh I feel
like you got a more interesting answer
than me so you go well I'll I'll I'll
say a few things and these are a bit
frame breaking
um and so the reason I'm bringing this
up is because I think someone once said
like
or at least this attitude exists a lot
in Silicon Valley where they're like
What's your exit plan and then
everyone's like [__] exit plans don't
have an Exit Plan uh you're not building
things to sell great things get bought
they don't get sold or something like
that and I actually think that's
nonsense I actually think if you want
you can build a company where you're
like I'm gonna exit in like four or six
years or two years and I'm gonna make
like tens of millions or hundreds of
millions whatever like you can build a
company like that and I think it could
be really successful
um and so one of a couple frame breaking
things that I had the first one building
something from scratch is a very very
rare skill and one or two focused
entrepreneurs with close to no money can
probably do more in six months than a 50
person team with millions of dollars in
12 months inside of a large organization
and that was actually really challenging
to me I remember HubSpot said they
wanted to buy us and I'm like Doc Just
Launch your own thing like I don't why
would you do you know what I mean and
being in at HubSpot now for two years I
see it's really hard the reason it's
really hard is the creative types who
who are bold enough to go and build
something they either aren't working at
that company because they're out doing
their own thing or they're just stuck in
this political game where they want to
impress their boss and it's not because
a company's bad it's just this is the
natural thing they don't want to
embarrass themselves they don't have a
significant amount of upside to see the
win they don't get the dopamine Rush of
the sale coming into Shopify and it's
actually really really really hard to
build something from scratch and so it's
worth it to them just to buy something
that's already working
do you agree with that
um and you can see it when an
acquisition happens the velocity of
progress slows down like molasses it is
uh it's like kind of remarkable now that
doesn't mean it fails but the velocity
definitely slows down other things go
better but the velocity and the pace and
the sort of like
um yeah the aggression and productivity
I think go down and that's what I
describe as anxiety goes way down as an
entrepreneur your anxiety goes way down
your frustration way up that's the
trade-off that you're going to make
however this is another thing where I
made this mistake where I would dismiss
big companies and I would call them
idiots
that's actually in my experience not
true and talking to a lot of people
sometimes it's false they are idiots but
sometimes
um operating like if you're around good
operators just like a good employee at a
big company they can be significantly
better operators and a lot of the things
that we make fun of bureaucracy meetings
things like that that creates redundancy
and if you do it correct redundancy
creates
um predictability and predictability
creates a value and that's why your
anxiety goes down and so a lot of that
big company stuff a lot of it's [__]
a lot of it's really necessary and the
people inside those companies can
actually operate things really really
well do you agree with that
[Music]
um
I agree that that's true
I wouldn't say that that's the main
value the main value that I saw inside
of a big company was that when you're
big
um
you have usually two things one is
distribution
so you could take something that doesn't
have a lot of distribution and give it
more distribution or you could simply
say I don't really need to innovate let
all these other people innovate and I'll
just follow because I have size and so
when I have size I don't need speed
right and so it's like a sumo wrestler
versus uh you know a sprinter or like a
uh you know a a lightweight you know a
lightweight wrestler or something like
that and so you basically trade that
distribution in size for for Speed I
think that's the the first thing and um
very hard to have both
um and you know the when you're at a
startup the EXP the mistakes are very
expensive
but when you're sorry when you're at a
startup the mistakes are not expensive
like I don't know how many things you do
with the hustle that were like dumb or
stupid or whatever just like roll it
back
um you know at the beginning especially
you know whatever I don't have any
customers anyways I don't have much
revenue to lose anyways and I have a
reputation to be burned the Press is not
watching me uh Twitter doesn't care what
I do whereas when you're big then your
every move matters and every mistake is
quite expensive
um and so you have to be a little more
careful and so careful is not a bug it's
a feature when it's a big company and so
I started to appreciate that they're not
slow because they're stupid
they're slow actually because they're
smart because they don't need to go fast
because they got size and mistakes are
expensive so they don't take they don't
try to make too many mistakes and
um you know by going too fast
and that brings me to my second to last
point which is a lot of cool [__] that
you and I like to make you you and I are
zero to one people like by definition
we're not the best at one to whatever
but a lot of the cool [__] is completely
illogical or really stupid and a lot of
the best stuff starts that way this
podcast you called it my first million
pretty horrible name
um my thing was called The Hustle pretty
bad name and it was just a newsletter
that's kind of like not like when I
pitch it to bigger companies they go
this is stupid this will never be big
and the reason why it existed anyway was
because I was beholden to no one we just
said math whatever screw it we're just
gonna do it when you're launching
something within a big company you have
to have logic you have to have reasoning
you have to like make a point because
you have to justify it for someone to
fund it uh whereas when you're a nobody
just two guys you say nah screw up we're
just gonna do this we're gonna have an
anti-black Friday sale where we charge
more this Friday as opposed to less and
just because just because we want to
because this is funny it's completely
illogical and illogical stuff works not
all the time sometimes when I was
hanging out with the 70 year old person
I was explaining I said yeah I'm
thinking about what I want to do next
and you know
I really want to pick a good project I
want to pick a right the right way to
spend my time
um
and he goes uh
picking is hard and he goes
and the hard thing about picking is that
today
she might look like a pimply chubby
person you know here
but 12 months from now as you take that
idea you start dating it and then you
kind of pivot over here you change one
thing get a new wardrobe
all of a sudden she's 120 pounds she's
you know she's uh got her PhD and
she just got word in the mail she's
inheriting 72 million dollars and he's
like he gave me this analogy and he goes
that's the problem with picking is that
the best things don't always look like
the best things up front
this comes back to a Peter Thiel saying
which is the best ideas are things that
sound like bad ideas but are actually
good ideas and um why because those
things have the least competition those
things are the least done those things
have the highest upside because of the
most Greenfield uh things that are
obviously good ideas
are super competitive things that are
actually bad ideas doesn't matter how
hard you work they're bad ideas so The
Sweet Spot is something that sounds like
a bad idea but is actually a good idea
and that's you know this guy put it in a
uh you know you know a different kind of
analogy that I I appreciated and uh I
could just I'm glad I didn't you know
say who because you know people get mad
about that analogy but I thought it was
hilarious and I understood what he meant
which is you know when you started tell
when you started the hustle
you were like oh great it's this
conference and I was like you know
conference okay immediately like a lot
of work you know seasonal doesn't get
that big who cares if your product can
get rained out it's kind of not good
yeah yeah you have 200 tickets to your
conference like all right Sam good luck
you know and then you kind of fumbled
and then you were like oh okay
conference is working but you know
conference ain't where it's at but I've
been using content to drive ticket sales
maybe I should just do this content
thing through a newsletter and even that
was still sort of pimply and didn't
really newsletter I mean uh dude people
over here make it flying cars and Uber
and you're doing a newsletter like get
some ambition bro like you know that
that can't be big possibly right like
aren't newsletters just like a personal
thing people send out to their 50
friends
and you kind of figured it out as you go
and then now people are like yeah how
many freaking I want to build the next
hustle you know hustle for X you know
how many people pitch you that myself
included milk Road was a hustle cop yet
after I made fun of you for the for
doing a newsletter back in the day I was
like you know I didn't invest in your
thing because I was like I don't think
that's gonna get huge right and I was
like but you knew some you figured
something out along the way that was not
obvious up front and by the way the
hustle is very close to Crossing three
million subscribers and that brings me
to my last point which is
planning is something that I had never
done like when people were talking about
okrs which is like a framework for
running your company they would put it
on a quarterly scale and I'm like yeah
how about a weekly how about a weekly
one so we could like every single day
we're gonna create something new and
that's really important for starting out
and I don't think you should plan too
much right you can't worry about a b z
uh which is I I actually came we we both
uh separately had like the same thing
where I'm like I care about steps one
and steps two and then like I'll worry
about step I think about step 10 as
inspiration but I don't worry about
three four and five
um and so that's important when starting
stuff
but one I don't know when that point is
maybe 10 million 100 million in Revenue
I don't know what it is but planning is
needed it's necessary and it's
incredibly important and that's what big
companies do really well or they try to
do it well and as I'm growing my new
thing I'm trying to like bake this in of
like planning and not worrying about
like uh looking like
like you know I could have like a
quarterly plan it's okay I could I could
even have like a six month plan I
remember when we were selling the hustle
we sold we were around four years old
and they wanted like a five-year
projection and I'm like
what like uh that's that that's not even
like I I can't even comprehend five
years I don't even know if I'm gonna be
interested in this yeah one of these
nuts what are you talking about
you want me to write down a lie yeah my
lies are verbal there's no paper trail
he's trying to get me to write this down
dude it was ridiculous and now I
understand like it's actually okay to
like kind of have some of these plans so
anyway that's my list of things that
I've learned like being like seeing the
buyers
um perspective just a little bit and I
was just curious if you had any insights
it might be too early yeah well let me
tell you the different things that
they've done so first they hired a bunch
of people we were running the thing with
basically three or four people and then
one one freelancer right like it was
very very lean they you know
basically one dude wrote the email every
day and then me or Ben edited it and
that was like that's how the the whole
product the whole product was basically
created by that now there's like a
second writer there's an editor there's
a head of content it's like who who are
all these people what are they doing uh
is it is the content getting better I'm
not sure right like but they've hired up
people which like you said builds
redundancy because if the main guy got
sick which happened a couple times it
was like red you know Red Alert yeah um
you know if we got a fact wrong it's
like I didn't have time to check it you
know like you know we didn't we didn't
have those things in place and so you
know I think they've they've basically
taken I would just say in general they
took a longer term View
they were like okay we're gonna be doing
this for a number of years so what do we
need to get to this point two years from
now and let's start taking those steps
today where I was like all right next
month what would be sweet yeah well
because you're like planning exercise
you're in survival mode I had a even if
it was a survival mode because it was
like okay we got the business working it
would be like
I just wanted every day to be a new
adventure and like that's not how these
people think when they are like
long-term oriented they want each day to
not be an adventure they want each day
to be like you know it's the difference
between you know
um
you know people who go for these like
long hikes and uh you know a sprinter
and like you know I was just more of a
sprinter and so literally our goal
planning we would say like what's the
minimum thing that would feel like a win
we call it a good win ah that was good
and then what's the F yeah win where we
would be like f yeah dude we did ABC
right that happened and that's and we
that would create our goal and then we
would shoot for the feat we would make
sure we don't miss the good
um and like that's what we did every
single month and it was a little bit
more
um and if we didn't hit it it was a
problem like I immediately was like soul
searching like everybody stop and let's
figure out where we've gone wrong I'm
ready to change every anything and
everything which is not always the right
approach sometimes it is right like
these things serve you and then
sometimes they hurt you and so I would
say these guys they put more money into
growth they hired more people
and they don't panic there's the three
differences between us uh and I think
their approach has some bad things and I
think it has some great things and we'll
see you know how it all plays out now I
think I read somewhere where someone was
like I was reading some like thing about
masculinity and like the difference
between a man and a boy and like a real
man doesn't let like lots of different
uh or doesn't let like shallow input
change his emotions and change his plans
and I remember when I was running my
company I would always get emotional I'm
like no man if I gotta be a man I gotta
like be calm and I can't panic and I
used to think like oh no it was cool to
be like Mark Zuckerberg and seeing go go
in and see oh this isn't right you're
[__] fired it's like no real men
don't do that you know they could like
they don't panic and they don't freak
out and that kind of changed my
perspective on that a little bit Yeah my
trainer he's been teaching me this he's
like Okay so
like you know you're doing a set so
you're you're bench you're bench
pressing or whatever and let's say you
picked away that the first you know
three reps four reps are easy the next
four reps are getting harder and then
the last three four reps let's say
you're going to twelve uh the last four
reps you're like you know it's kind of
shaky and you want a spot but more than
anything I don't know for you but for me
it was always like get to the end it's
like I wanna um I don't want to quit I
don't want to quit I want to get there
but like I would start rushing and when
you rush your form changes and when you
rush you don't actually have that time
under tension that actually look at you
wow time under attention yeah
classic classic muscle building words I
like it don't make me say glycogen so so
he's like um he's like those last four
reps you're trying to get them done but
that's where all the all the games are
in that that last bit and he's like
that's where I want you to show Poise
slow and actually slow it down like
don't just like do normal speed go even
slower than your your normal Pace was to
maximize what you get out of it and so
then that became it's like okay when you
feel that Sizzle when you feel that burn
that's the reaction is not panic and
Rush it's Poise so I took that I was
like okay that's the lesson in the gym
but the gym is just a metaphor for life
so now I'm doing that same thing
everywhere as soon as I feel that Sizzle
and that burn and I just want to get out
of there I want to get done with it I'm
like no no Now's the Time to be poisoned
and slow it down and so that's been
working wonders in the business world
because it's like just when everybody
thinks shit's hitting the fan
I'm like all right this is the time
where we where we where we go poised we
lock in and we calmly address the
situation versus
trying to react overreact and react to a
to a stimulus this my friend is called
growth Sean you are experiencing growth
congratulations you're doing it right in
front of all of our eyes and in our ears
you're showing growth what topic you
want to do next we're in a weird middle
terminal yeah let's do
um do you have anything little let me
see if I got something little by the way
while you're looking you have to tell me
what to do for my researcher now I have
400 applicants I've narrowed it down to
200 and I'm like I don't know what to do
with these people you have to tell me
how to like you should just tell them to
do basically just give them the
assignment which is uh I'll tell you
what to do okay I'll tell you how to do
this okay so the what I would do is the
best way to work together best way to
know if you want to work with them is to
just do a project rather than interview
them you don't want to interview 400 or
even 20 people that would just take up
way too much time so you give them all
the assignment the assignment is hey
every week
um here's the things that we do I want
you to surface interesting nuggets that
I might find interesting I did that all
400 people did that dude okay so who are
the best 25 from that and did you do it
for like two or three like have them do
it
for like two weeks be like uh you know
hey do this for two weeks if you do it
I'm gonna pay you you know I'll pay you
250 bucks if you get through all the all
the things that might be a lot of money
I don't know do the math but like do
something so they're not working totally
for free
um or cut the bottom like 200 people
right away and then just be like hey do
this because because I think it's easy
to do once and it's really hard to do
for three weeks straight A lot of people
could do a great MFM podcast once I
don't know how many of them could do
this podcast 100 times 100 episodes a
year and that's what we do and so you
kind of need a researcher who's able to
who has some inflow of information that
that they can steadily be curating good
stuff and then the second thing is give
them a couple of research topics so be
like uh the way I do it is sometimes I
give them an assignment to bring me
interesting nuggets but then I bring
nuggets and I say hey take this story
and uh I want you to research here's
what I want and I basically gave them a
format so my format for them is
you want I want you to come up with the
frame so the frame is the the framing of
the topic how will I just bring this up
out of the blue on MFM right so let's
say there's some interesting growth hack
uh the frame might be
you know here's three of my favorite
growth hacks that I've seen in the past
year
right because just talking about this
one randomly doesn't work or let's say
it's a growth hack but actually
um or let me give the example the Nugget
was
um I bought a car from an anonymous
account on Twitter so that's a cool
frame that's like a hook for a good
story but we changed it to the guy Mafia
so I bought it from car dealership guy
but you know what there are all these
guys and actually maybe there's a bigger
topic here that's called the guy Mafia
and people like that that frame right so
I teach them I'm like you gotta hit me
with a possible frame
then you got to have the supporting like
evidence like what are the four or five
interesting bullet points talking points
that I could say about this thing that
would make you say oh that's cool that's
interesting and then what's the take or
the takeaway and the take of the
takeaway and let's say for the guy Mafia
was
it was first it was here's why this
works but then I was like no no a better
take would be here's what I think people
should be doing you should be doing this
with a girl Anonymous account because I
think it'll get more followers you
should be doing it in all these other
categories and then don't monetize with
a newsletter or paid paid Community
monetize by selling the actual thing
like selling me the car and so that was
the take and so I I tease on like here's
a little Excel table and for every story
you got to fill out the frame the
talking points and the take and um I see
it yeah I'm good at that most people by
the way are very bad at that that's okay
I'm like our skill is we need to be able
to do that but them doing it poorly is
still super helpful because you're like
no no that's a shitty frame the frame's
got to be this and that's still better
than a blank page I need you to send me
all this yeah I will
yeah I need I need help with this it's
been very challenging yeah these are the
these are the tricks of the trade that
other people we're giving these out for
free now I remember once remember the
the TV show um the P Diddy one where
he's trying to find a rapper yeah and
he's like I need you to go to Brooklyn
and give me some milk and you like make
them walk across the bridge you know
what I'm talking about
like makes him walk across to get a
bucket cupcake like five miles because
that's how he started his career he was
a runner yeah a record label and he had
to go get [__]
um but he had this thing where he was in
the studio and he's like he's like uh
sing it and then they they sang it he's
like uh sing it again they're like wow
it wasn't that good he goes no we need
to make a double what's a double he's
like a double as you say the same exact
thing and we layer the two audio tracks
and makes your voice sound more full and
powerful and it just sounds better and
he turned to the camera he's like I
shouldn't be saying all this [__] on
camera and uh and I remember literally
like I was in seventh grade when that
show came out and I was like I just
heard a trick at the train and I've
never forgot that even though I'm not a
rapper I never used it but literally I
was like make space in the brain
he just kind of made it sound like he
just gave me an Insider tactic and I
literally like still remember this now
I'm 34 years old and I still remember
this that's hilarious that's hilarious I
just heard it that's good
um all right let's get out of here
[Music]